yeah yeah that's a that's a whole nother
DJ thing as a bummer that's a bummer if
you don't know what we're talking about
TJ Dillashaw tested positive for
injectable EPO which is a serious
performance-enhancing substance and in
some circumstances according to Jeff
Novitzky it's given people strokes and I
had heard this too that like young guys
doing like Tour de France type shit
would have strokes because they were
taking too much EPO because you know I
could be supposed to take one take two
fuck it anybody who's gonna do that yeah
that you know it turns your your your
blood to paint and I think that's what I
guess that's probably the discipline
right of how people were always getting
away with things beforehand right is to
try to maybe try to do it in a way where
there won't get caught but I think
that's like it well this much is good
and yeah this much more is gonna be
better and yeah and we know guys who've
done that with TRT you know there was a
few trt tests where they when trt was
legal testosterone replacement therapy
where you would hear about guys tests in
like 1400s 1470 like which is insane
it's like superhuman no person's ever
lived that as 1,400 like as a natural
walking around testosterone level that's
crazy hyper human right but they just
get these benefits from that well some
of these people though who walk around
naturally I wonder if they'd never been
tested though that's true yeah some of
these people I see walking around like
genetic freaks yeah that looks like he
was born on steroids yeah there are some
freaks man there's some legit genetic
freaks to deny that would be crazy
there's some people that just like Yoel
Romero yeah what in the fuck it doesn't
matter how many steroids you take it
doesn't matter what you do like you do
look like that you have to be a genetic
freak yeah you know they're and they're
out there alright it's not fair talking
about he would say go to Cuba yeah jeans
go see the jeans don't you but look
around yeah what's his name mom
the fighter from France the heavyweight
from France I mean he fastest in Ghana
well yeah Francis in Ghana wasn't uh guy
who used to be the one who had the the
crazy fat would pat pat berry Oh II
checked Congo Cheick Kongo oh yeah
Adonis yeah sculpted Greek statue yeah
he's always imagined like I want to go
to where he comes from take a look
around probably super athletes yeah
probably a lot of meteors
um the TJ thing apparently they went and
tested his old fight pissed with Cody
too and that tested positive for EPO as
well and then Cody started freaking out
yeah what do you do if they if they go
back what if they decide to go back hey
and say fuck it let's test all the
fights and it finds out that he was
doing it like five six seven fights what
do you do well yeah and then what do you
do if you uh but then it's a whole
nother can of worms too because like all
the fights and then what about all that
because right like when we get a test to
everybody yeah Rob and I were joking
around last night and I was like test
them all and he's going no test him all
test everything let's find out let's
know what it was let's know what it was
and he's like what if they had piss
samples from you know 10 years ago 15
years ago like what if they could use
you sadhus style testing right today in
the past I'm so glad that all these
things are above my paygrade
yeah yeah I was in the office right now
the in charge of that program you have
to really wonder where is the line you
certainly want to test a guy for a fight
that happened a week ago you certainly
want to hold you know and check his if
some new testing methods come out if
there was a fight from a year ago you
certainly would check that how many
years back to you go though yeah
especially if it's not expensive like
what if it's easy and cheap to test so
yeah no it's not 500 tests on the last
500 championship fights and then you
have like 400 fights they now have to
like change the result of
yeah I don't know I don't know either
yeah yeah it's night I was joking around
I was saying test them all I was taking
the the fun position test them all
I don't know that mmm I mean look we all
know at one point in time
performance-enhancing drugs were a huge
part of mixed martial arts and that's
why the UFC stepped up and decided to
institute this program I think there's a
big part of it I think it's a big part
of professional sports in general sure
yeah and I think that um you know combat
sports you know has a government
oversight that other sports don't have
so I think their work on we're gonna be
it's gonna be coming up regardless
anyway so I think maybe that's whether
you know the UFC took a position right I
think of the other sports I mean guys
get caught doing things but a lot of the
other sports regulate themselves right
mm-hmm yeah I don't know I think the NFL
regulates itself what if this court has
what other sport has a governing body
like an athletic commission saying hey
we're gonna show up and do this or do
that I don't know what do they do with
baseball I don't know I don't know maybe
I don't know I don't know much about
other sports but I didn't I've never
I've never heard I've never heard of
like a we all know about we you know
that's something different our sport is
the government involved we have a
commission but not not not like you seen
a government Commission but they did yet
they're governing themselves the NFL
would have a vote they hand down a
suspension they're not fair from this
this guy suspension of that guy's
suspension and baseball they have like a
three-strike rule if the first time is
like somewhere in the 10 to 25 game
range and then the second one is like
half the season third one out for a
whole year and if you do it again you're
banned yeah but there's no outside and
shows up and decides to test your
champion right just the baseball NFL
I've asked once all right what's the but
let's say you have a big moneymaker in
your sport and then somebody outside of
your company just comes along and says
yeah I'm I'm the government by they have
the right to test this guy yeah like
what happened with Jon Jones yeah I mean
that's that's a perfect example I mean
the UFC did not want Jon Jones to test
positive he is the biggest star right
now other than Connor and Connor is not
active and Jon Jones is fighting all the
time he wants to fight all
the time that if that's but that's the
only way you ever find out what's really
going on is you hire a bunch of
werewolves and they just let him loose
right go check this go go out there
check check every one they checked the
shit out of people I was looking at this
list of people that Holly Holm's been
tested more than like I think the I
think Nowitzki might have put Steve
paimio chick tweeted it because he'd
been tested 38 times really yeah some
people it's like in the 40s Cris cyborg
got tested a lot yeah and Holly Holm got
tested a lot huh yeah
yeah Holly Holm got tested a lot a lot
of people got tested it's just like you
crazy numbers and a lot of them I
guarantee you they're waking them up
yeah get em up like 6:00 in the morning
that's what this whatever I mean I don't
know what they go but I've heard
conversations a little bit it doesn't
seem like it they want to make sure you
the air so they get there early in the
morning that's fucked up you're supposed
to tell them where you're supposed to
where you're gonna be at anything yeah
yeah the problem is if you're training
hard that 8 to 10 is so huge you might
get hit with a punch if they wake you up
after like 6 hours or five hours it's
possible that a punch might connect on
you that wouldn't have connected if you
got ate that's not precious yeah yeah
yeah that's that's real that's real
right real everybody knows when you how
you feel good in the gym and everybody
even if you just lift weights
there's days you feel good there's days
you feel like crap make sure I showed up
here well-rested
you look well round and I'm hydrated I'm
gonna get back I did I did hydrate yeah
I don't know it's just it's it's just
not smart to stop athletes in the middle
of their training camp and wake them up
yeah I mean I get the testing but I feel
like the testing so sophisticated you
could get to them at noon okay just you
could get to them in noon you got good
testing now just so we don't we I mean I
don't know that I don't know that either
I'm talking shit yeah because I think
the best time right the best time is
that you know maybe at the earliest
earlier the better right maybe I don't
know the thing about this EPO apparently
and this is a Shah was telling me was
that they didn't it didn't used to be
detectable the way it is now
they've
they've got these new methods of
detection and EPO s12 that apparently
from what I've read don't listen to me
I'm not a doctor they can absolutely
tell that you injected it it's it's
injectable it comes in the injectable
form that's what's in the body so
there's no chance of a tainted stated
supplement right right it's definitely
EPO so that's that's fucked up is that
apparently that stuff has a giant
advantage it gives you an anabolic
advantage it also gives you crazy
recuperative powers so like you could
train really hard and then be ready to
go the next day what do you think the
answer is because like for me like this
is all stuff that like to be honest I
don't really pay that much attention to
it because I don't have I also
it's out of my wheelhouse to deal with
but also it's hard to have an answer
like you said like do we go back and
keep testing them when these new things
come and says what we do with the whole
yeah yeah it's just it's very
interesting you know yeah what do you do
with the history books that's that's
what you'd say like at what point if you
have samples that date back 10 years do
you do test them all what do you do I
don't know I don't know how long they
keep samples or who has them or how they
you know what's the chain of command I
don't know man it's just but if you find
out that TJ tested positive for the Cody
fight - well Cody sure has an argument
there and what if it's the fight before
that what if there's a lot of that
there's a lot of people who have
arguments yeah there's a lot of guys
yeah so it's yeah it's up to me it's a
shame too because I'm a TJ fan and I
think he's a phenomenal fighter and I am
I'm a big fan of watching him perform
but just it taints his legacy it just
does there's no way around it when when
you get caught cheating which is this
stuff is there's no way it's not
cheating I mean this is just cheating
right I mean this isn't any accident
it's it taints your legacy right the guy
had an amazing legacy you know two-time
bantamweight champion one of the best
pound-for-pound fighters the way he beat
Hannon Burrell I was like holy shit so
he went out and fought hand in virology
was sparring right yeah yeah his stuff
tough stuff
some of his fights were amazing he's
amazing doesn't take away from the fact
that he's amazing
TJ's an amazing fighter but fuck man the
to test positive for EPO and Henry
cejudo fuck there's also crazy to watch
the progression all the work he did and
how much you know he was getting better
every fight and so he focused yeah but
you got to think like how much like if
you're on EPO
how much does that really allow you to
train extra time how much does that
allow you to recover what's the Bennett
what is the quantifiable benefit it must
be pretty significant because there's a
lot of you know the cyclists a lot of a
lot of heavy-duty endurance athletes use
it and I almost want to try it you know
they say that these executives are
trying it they're doing EPO and entering
into triathlons and shit like that for
bragging rights
yeah just assholes I suppose with money
or taking EPO like really I was reading
the thing about an epidemic of really
boost you that much like okay you're
gonna take it and you're gonna notice
that you're able to like like the other
day you could barely finish a roll a
loop around the Rose Bowl a three-mile
loop and then you start taking it and
you can get what five six miles and I
wonder I wonder I think what it does is
it raises your threshold if you're
already an elite endurance athlete too I
think for them that's what it is it's
like they're already looking for that
extra edge so they're already in elite
endurance athletes already in the Tour
de France then they take that EPO and
it's like wow just you just jacks them
up they could just do more work they
have more oxygen they don't run out of
juice and Frank I like TJ his style is
so kinetic there's so much movement
explosion some juice dances like he
needs that juice it's not like a calm
easy game where he's you know
everything's fast fast fast fast fast
it's crazy it's hard it it's it's a hard
one to swallow
yeah meant so for me like I was like man
I was gonna come on Joe Rogan's show and
see what was he to talk about to make me
uncomfortable to talk about maybe some
hard stoppages man I've talked about
some hard stoppages
give me what's the words well let me
talk about when I made a mistake I don't
want to talk about this you know I'll
just be a - I have no answer for it I
don't understand that it's like all I'd
wanted like I just doesn't feel like a
good conversation because all I could do
is just it just get like you said it's
just gonna take away from what I've seen
of as and then and the more I imagine
about it it's just going to be more take
away and then anything I could say or
think about I can't think of anything
that solution or our system yeah yeah
yeah I don't think anybody I mean I
think we're in this stage right now
where they're probably looking at the
data going okay what is this signify and
how many more people should we test
mm-hmm no once once they develop a new
method of testing that's the whole
reason why they want to keep the old
samples anyway in case new more
sensitive methods of detecting right are
invented and you know about this stuff
because I know that you you're a science
freak and you're saying dark dark
especially when it comes to anything
that can enhance the this life that we
have on this earth so yeah sure you know
a lot about this stuff well I've had a
really amazing conversation with many
people about it and David Sinclair was
one of more recent ones who did this
discussion about life extension and
different anti-aging solutions and
different things that they're coming up
with
but what I've come through with is at
the other end this there are probably
hundreds of thousands of people that are
involved in either legitimate
supplements or legitimate molecules or
testing hormones on people or you know
trying all these different things to try
to figure out how to get the body to
perform better some of them are legal
and some of them are illegal and that's
where it gets strange she get like the
guy like the ball code guy right Victor
Conte comes along I got one just rub it
on no one's gonna know shit they don't
know what this stuff is yet and for
awhile yeah that worked and then but but
why no but while worked everybody's like
hmm why is Barry Bonds getting so big
you know people just started wrecking
like come on man look at me sammy sosa
look at me in the eye what are you doing
you know and they all they're all like
exhibited these obvious physiological
changes where that you could tell them
whenever they were doing was really
effective stuff there's hundreds of
thousands of people working on that
right now
all the traps all the times trying to
get it better there's probably thousands
of people that are trying to come up
with stuff that sneaks past this testing